hey guys just a quick update video about
the future of my channel no big changes
or anything like that but I just wanted
to quickly make a video to talk about a
couple of things I am actually gonna
make a city skyline series again which
you're gonna see very soon actually I
have already made it which is the main
point sort of actually really like the
game and I have still been playing the
game I get a lot of questions about it
but I just haven't uploaded anything in
it yet since I figured I wasn't really
good enough yet tried a couple of cities
and they ultimately kind of field I
didn't really have enough material and
then really continue them but now I
think I've got something going which is
actually pretty good so I'll show that
off soon and aside from that I am also
planning on making videos of roller
coaster world or and planet coaster as
well I'm not gonna make any update
videos which is something that I also
get asked about sometimes but I'm not
going to make any videos showing off the
nearest development Diaries and things
like that you can just check that out on
their own websites or other youtubers
who might do it and you can ultimately
find me on the roller coaster [ __ ]
forums our the planet coaster forums you
really want to talk about it or you can
just do it in random comment section i
don't know but i do really follow the
development and i'll start making some
videos of the games when stay sort of
start appearing and about that that also
sort of means that i started playing
more games on my channel and be it's
still in the same corner of genres and i
kind of want to change the overall
design of my thumbnails so that's
something that I'm gonna want to mess
with as well it's not gonna change too
much still same fonts and same shadows
and all that stuff but I wanna
experiment with giving different games
different colors to kind of make it a
bit more clear because right now looking
at my channel it's a bit of a mess to be
very honest and this also probably means
that in the future i'll be using
different titles and stepping away from
the let's play title which is something
that i started with my roller coaster
cocoon 3 series which in the beginning
was actually a let's play with live
stuff but already in the first couple of
episodes started becoming more of a
time-lapse thing and i would still call
it let's play but i don't really feel
like in concept that really is a let's
play so
just to make things a little bit more
clear future series are going to have
different names which you kind of built
around whatever i'm building a very
comparative to what for example pieces
of prestige or flux Tron's the kind of
names that they have for their videos
that's the sort of thing that i'll
probably be moving towards though i'll
still call my current let's play so
that's place but yeah that's about it
the last thing that i kind of wanted to
say is happy new year because it's the
first of January and have a good 2016 I
actually had to think about what year it
is anyway see you later